if you see only the one side and it one
section of it the misery hopelessness
and devastations and disasters how
terrible the life is at the very bottom
of course you go crazy by seeing that
repeatedly but luckily for me while I
see that at the same time I see the
other part things are happening people
are getting happier it's children going
to school their children are growing up
healthier the nature of the house is
changing looks big prettier housed and
is used to be in a tattered house now
with cleaner house with the toilets with
the drinking water so I see the
tremendous amount of excitement
tremendous amount of ability in the
human beings and even among the poor
persons the fact that once they make one
tiny step how happy they get and if you
can place yourself at a role that you
make it happen in some way in some
indirect way you played some role and
you feel very happy that you made that
happen and you want to do more it's very
intoxicating experience once you do some
you want to do more because it's such a
such an experience for yourself so these
are the message that you bring up to
people and you see a lot of people are
supporting they would like to help live
like to come up and say how do we do it
more and you explain to them and many
people over these years now that I'm
doing it many people can do you remember
i met you to 10 years back 15 years back
and you changed my life and started this
and i'm running a program in this
country i used to work for a bank i used
to work for a company i left the job and
i am doing this so that makes me feel
happy that i played the role in his life
or in her life in making a decision and
she's enjoying it and he's enjoying it
that's a best part of it that they're so
I feel happy I see both sides of it
things that used to go wrong very badly
now things are coming into shape and a
process is started and road has been
built to which
step by step they're going in Bangladesh
a tremendous amount of poverty but the
poverty is declining but steadily so it
makes feel happy we are one country
which will be achieving millennium
development goal to reduce poverty
behalf by 2015 so that's an exciting
thing to happen that you see step by
step every year we are coming closer and
closer to millennium development goal
number one reducing poverty behalf and
we are also achieving all other
Millennium Development Goals so that by
the time will come to 2015 we achieve
all the eight millennium development
goals that's a very happy thing to
happen and we want to make sure we don't
kind of miss this opportunity to get
there we absolutely want to make sure
that all the man-made millennium
development goals are achieved in very
comfortable way not in a kind of
last-minute rush to that we go step by
step we are right on the track back now
so these are the things which makes me
feel happy
you